so we're told that rayo L is
perpendicular ray o n so oh L is
perpendicular to n so we know that this
right over here is a right angle or it's
a 90-degree angle then they tell us that
the measure of angle LOM is equal to 2x
plus 46 so L o M so this angle right
over here is equal to 2x plus 46 and
then this angle then they tell us that
the measure of angle mo n is equal to 3x
minus 6 so M o n so this angle right
over here is 3 X minus 6 and so they
asked us find angle mo n so we need to
find this angle right over here and we'd
be able to find it if we knew what X is
if we knew what X is and assumed to be 3
times that minus 6 now the one thing
that we know is that if we add up these
two angles these are adjacent angles and
they're outside Ray's form a right angle
so these two angles are going to add up
to 90 degrees and I guess we can assume
here that we're dealing in degrees so
let's say that 2 X 2 X plus 46 plus plus
3 X minus 6 is going to add up to 90
degrees these two angles are
complementary so it's going to add up to
90 degrees or it's going to add up to 90
and now we just have to simplify we have
2 X's so we have another 3 X's so you
add those two you're going to get 5 X's
and then you have 46 and you're going to
subtract 6 so it's going to be plus 40
is equal to 90 is equal to 90 subtract
40 from both sides let's do that
subtract 40 from both sides and on the
left hand side you're just left with a
5x and on the right hand side you are
left with a 50 now just divide both
sides by 5 and we are left with X is
equal to 10 now our answer is not 10
we've just figured out what X is we
asked us for is what's the measure of
angle mo n well we already know that the
measure of angle M o n is equal to 3x
- six which is equal to 3 times 10 3
times 10 minus 6 that I wanted at minus
6 in that green color minus 6 which is
equal to 24 24 degrees